[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome back this pork
shell is still obsessing over the last
Jedi and today we're going to learn some
brand-new behind-the-scenes secrets
about the costumes of the last Jedi yes
stuff I didn't even know joining me
today is Ichi online writer Desiree
Murphy who not only attended the costume
design Awards on Tuesday night but had a
pretty lengthy interview with episode
seven and eight costume designer Michael
Kaplan yes Ashley thank you for having
me so Michael recently called me from
London where he gave me the scoop on
what exactly went into creating the most
memorable looks from the last Jedi I'm
talking carrie fisher's high collar
Laura Dern's a purple hair and even
shirtless kylo Ren talk about that
there's a story behind cheerless kylo
Ren okay well let's run down everything
I think I want to start with canto bite
because I think the casino scene there
is like there are so many costumes
there's so much going on there I mean
did he talk about what went into
creating that whole sequence he did and
I'm actually so glad that you're kicking
off this episode with that because out
of everything we saw in the last Jedi
that was actually one of my favorite
sequences it actually reminded me a
little bit of the Met Gala which is like
fashions biggest night for celebrities
right there in this formal dress for
Star Wars and to kind of put that into
perspective Michael said for other Star
Wars films when you're having a few
hundred extras you know they're all kind
of in uniform you're picking up pieces
that they're not really standing out and
everybody but with this it's like
everyone had their own individual look
and he said that he pays a lot of
attention to detail so every single
person and not only actor and actors but
also the creatures were addressed in
these formal where he can create it so
not only the ball gowns but also the
head head pieces and the accessories the
gloves and just think about how much
work that was yeah because I'm imagining
like in previous Star Wars movies
there's always like a cantina and this
and Kanto by it was kind of the cantina
but it we've never seen this like
high-end version of that so these people
are in like people creatures whatever
are in just drab brown gear and then
this is like everyone needs to
high-fashion yes and I love the scene I
thought he did an incredible job with it
and he actually told me too that Rian
Johnson loved it so much but he kept
apologizing to him because so much of
this had to be cut out because the movie
was already so long already and he also
said that because of that reason he's
really hoping that Ryan will put some
more of the candle bite scene and you
know close-ups on those beautiful
costumes in the extended scenes that
we'll get to see in March I hope yours
cross yeah I'd love to see more there
are two hours of bonus material there so
I can't wait also Rian Johnson I believe
you owe me an apology as well you know
why speaking of regal high fashion we've
got to talk about Princess Leia because
like she's always royalty to me gonna
talk about Carrie Fisher
I had heard she had a lot of input into
her costume in terms of like the space
jewelry but what if I mean what if I
could Caplan tell you about her look yes
okay amazing iconic like you said but
basically as soon as he knew that he was
going to be working on this project with
Ryan Ryan told him you know I want Aleya
for this episode where she's regal she's
more elegant she's princess like so that
being said he's like okay how can we do
this and he decided to do it with
jewelry and capes so with the jewelry he
told me that they actually recycled two
pieces one was a ring from force awakens
and then also the earrings that were
like kind of cuffed in her ear from
force awakens just in a different finish
so they look totally different which is
cool that's got to be at the end with
that jewelry he was like okay we have
these two pieces now how can we expand
basically they just added more rings and
jewelry for accessories and then with
the capes he said he loved these so much
because they just framed Carrie Fisher
so well totally agree with him on that
right and they just really gave that
regal quality that Ryan Johnson wanted
and on top of that with the caves you
know he really likes costumes where you
can wear them in different ways so
that's kind of the inspiration between
that high collar that she had that look
that we all loved on Twitter right
but it was basically because you know
he's like okay what can we do with this
costume where she's appearing on camera
so many times in this movie how can we
make it look different so he popped the
collar and he went to Ryan and said you
know I like this look what do you think
about it and Ryan said I know exactly
the scene we can use that for oh wow yes
so the the costume dictated like he that
scene was already there but then the
collar is the Michael Kaplan and that's
the amazing thing about costume design I
mean it can make or break a scene or
character and I feel like this one
specifically was so well done we just
see Carrie Fisher looking across the
battlefield looking as regal as can be
and yeah it was so powerful
yeah such a wonderful shot as well yeah
um did he speak about you know Carrie's
kind of legacy after she passed on and
what he what it meant to him to kind of
design for her posthumously I guess yeah
so this was really interesting and I
wanted to ask about it because you know
they I knew that they had developed kind
of a close friendship over time but I
didn't know how well and they actually
went to dinner a lot into the movies and
with Carrie he didn't necessarily say
that she had a lot of input but he said
that she was very happy with the
costumes and very comfortable because
for her she didn't like really being
fussed over on set right yeah so that
was a really good thing she was like
okay this is so great I can be
underdressed just pop the cape on when
it's time for a scene and I'm ready to
go but I wanted to ask him specifically
you know it's like we obviously had the
tragic death with Carrie were also sad
about it but for him to watch this movie
and now know like I'm the one that was
responsible for creating her final looks
right as Princess Leia now right he
shared a really sweet story and I don't
feel like I can give those words justice
I know we have an audio pretty close
with her and as well as her daughter
Billie the whole family for quite some
time so when she passed away it was
pretty devastating and I certainly
got an email from Ryan saying that he
was editing the film and he said I know
you haven't seen Carrie on film yet you
know I'm still editing it but he said
I'm I'm so happy you were her costume
designer and you made her look so
wonderful for our last film so that made
me feel you know very proud and and you
know it was nice that I know I honestly
when he was speaking to me about that I
just kind of had chills because I
obviously didn't know Carrie I know you
met her once you interviewed her very
briefly but I just can't even imagine
being on set with the crew and then
having to watch this film be made and
really do it justice for her and you
know she was like I'm not wearing any
version of a metal bikini so exactly
this is well I think another standout in
in the movie and on the women's side
holding time for the women would be
Laura Dern's yes look at this right here
vice-admiral hold oh yeah so I have a
really interesting story about this so
on the phone Michael told me that
Laura's hair originally wasn't supposed
to be purple in this film really yes he
had a completely different idea but it
was Laura who wasn't kind of she wasn't
really thrilled with the idea of having
this color and we have an audio clip of
that that won't play - oh okay
personally I didn't think purple hair
was very Star Wars and I wanted her to
have you know kind of over hair which I
thought would be really really beautiful
and elegant she thought it would kind of
look like grey hair and you know wasn't
thrilled with the idea so I think it was
Ryan who thought well why don't we have
the hair match the dress that's how that
came about
that's crazy cuz I like the purple I've
had purple hair before um oh yeah I mean
I guess I see what she's saying but
that's so funny that she had so much
input into like what her character yeah
I like the purple - I know some people
had different feelings about it but I
thought it looks great I mean with the
jersey dress especially that was so
great I loved it I know
people are always like why are these
like ranking officials dress like regal
Queens and I'm like because they can
wouldn't you
ryan johnson can do whatever you want
right yes again um okay here's what I
really want to get to because you
mentioned at the beginning of the video
and now I'm been thinking about this
whole time guys
let's talk about shirtless kylo Ren okay
we can I know you asked me before was
Michael responsible for this yeah I had
to ask him point-blank were you
responsible for shirtless and basically
yes so when he was talking with Ryan it
was always kind of known that Adam
driver was gonna be shirtless right so
Michaels idea was you know how are we
gonna make him like Adam driver is so
buff he's in such good shape
who knew yeah but with Star Wars he
wanted to make sure that the body was
seen in an interesting way and also you
know Star Wars is a period film not
contemporary and he thought it would be
out of place if he had Adam in you know
like trendy hip hop and jeans or even
like low baggy jeans right oh my god so
he's like it has to be something that he
was wearing a blue jays yes so he yeah
he put him in these high-waisted way up
here Pam did and did he like see the
memes like does he think it's funny or
is he just like like did he have a
reaction to that yeah he did think it
was funny he specifically called out
John Mayer he saw that one and between
Travis Kyle oh ciao yes he has and he
called that out specifically as well as
an article that he read about how all of
these people that are kylo Ren fans are
trying to dress like him and having such
a hard time because stores in the u.s.
don't sell pants that are up this high I
have a few pairs yeah ladies that might
not be so hard but I mean for the men
that are you know gonna be dressing this
Kyle for Halloween Comic Con what have
you you know players are creative gotta
get a cumberbund yeah I think cuz it's
like not only do you have to pull off
that you know buff Adam driver look you
also have to have those pants so that's
a big challenge
now I know you asked him about the
helmet because that's like watching your
own work get totally destroyed what did
he have to say
okay there was actually a lot of
laughter at this point but watching that
scene as a costume design fan myself I
was like oh man I can't imagine first of
all how many hours of work he put into
this only for it to be destroyed in
seconds and he said I actually heard him
say this before so you know that he
feels very passionate about this but he
said I would think that it's kind of
like how Obama felt when Trump's came in
and started changing all of his policies
there you have it oh my god jokes aside
he also said that he tries not to be too
tied to his costumes because he works on
a lot of action and adventure films so
things are getting destroyed all the
time
yeah oh my god I I was curious to know
about Snoke too because it is like a
motion capture performance but he does
have like that stylish gold robe did he
say like is that a real robe yes I loved
this okay so basically the inspiration
for Snoke was a combination of two
things one being that Ryan came to him
and said I want Snoke to be regal like
Leia and to the production design so he
knew early on that Snoke was going to be
in this red room with red walls red
floors red guards even so obviously he
wasn't gonna put him in that color
didn't want to put him in black because
they wouldn't pop enough but the gold
was someone with snoke stature too it
was just perfect and as far as the
material he said he and his team just
basically found this wonderful fabric
and had it gold-leafed which is why it
appeared so beautifully oh my gosh
that's crazy like I mean I don't the
costume design is like not my forte
believe it or not but it is crazy like
to think about he's like okay I have to
choose this color based on what the room
is gonna look like it's yeah like
there's the whole thing you know yeah
and I mean Snoke was seriously the focal
point of all those scenes yeah so I
thought again Michael doing a family job
and in that throne room they have the
guards next on the Praetorian guards
like he's got I mean we've seen like the
red guards next to the Emperor and stuff
but does he like to is that his costume
design as well those the armor and stuff
yeah so one thing Michael really pointed
out during our phone call about this was
that this was really a team effort he
has a design crew with him that works on
everything
and he said he was originally inspired
by muscle cars he wanted them to be red
and shiny but then it was actually his
team that came up with the actual design
of what those costumes were gonna be
because they need full range of motion
to fight weapon they also need to be
able to see and now watching the film
after hearing what he said it's very
interesting because if you look at the
helmets on the guards it appears like
they almost don't even have eye holes
right which is crazy to me but he said
he was really happy with those and he
said that you know a lot of people have
been vocal online about how happy they
were with those and that made him very
happy that entire scene is I mean
whenever I'm watching the last Jedi cuz
I've seen it a bunch of time I'm like
waiting to get to that scene I'm like
come on get the realistic well done I'm
just like oh I just want that throne
room scene for like on a loop for three
hours yeah I loved it
okay so he did he did seven and eight
yes did he say anything about taking on
Episode nine he is and he's currently
working on it but I asked him to spell
secrets and he said he's just completely
sworn to secrecy okay
we actually have audio of that let him
tell you guys I'm sorry I can't say a
word I'm sworn to secrecy and but I know
that JJ has a lot of amazing tricks and
and secrets up his sleeves and things
have disclosed to me and I'm very
excited about it and so I'm sure
everyone else will be - in 2019 yeah JJ
Abrams is like The Da Vinci Code when it
comes to secrets like anyone who works
with him cannot say a word I just can't
even like imagine being in Michaels
shoes and having to keep their secret
for so long
yeah there's no way I'm a bad secret
keeper um speaking which I know you
talked to Michael Kaplan about kind of
working with JJ verse Ryan and what that
was like
a bunch of other stuff that way yeah I
mean I could sit here and talk to you
all day about this chat with Michael it
was so amazing and he teased a bunch of
other things like
whether or not he makes a cameo in the
movie and what it was like dressing the
creatures in particular all of that is
in a huge article that's now up on ET
online so be sure to check it out yes
please do if there's so much more I
swear yeah and speaking of costumes by
the way I talked to you Donald Glover
whoo who's playing Lando Calrissian in
the next Star Wars movie soloist our
worst story that's out inmates so soon
but that is up on this very YouTube page
the police take a look and let me know
your thoughts and feelings and you guys
can talk to us on twitter.com all the
time all the time 24/7 like literally I
don't sleep may the porks be with you
and I'll see you guys next time